[Music]
now my mom was your emergency
there's a crazy guy in my high school
he's trying to beat me up if you have a
problem with a bully I need to speak to
a teacher no I am a teacher
excuse me it's actually another teacher
who wants to have a fight with me after
school so I need help
oh very funny you're gold man they're
gonna take that ass-whooping pop why are
you trying to pick a fight with me man
these students a [ __ ] on this school all
day you think this is funny i'ma show
you what's fun read it all he did it now
you got to pay the price snitches get
stitches what you talking about
mr. Strickland reputation of a hothead
scary yet effective am I the only one
here who sees what's going on ho hello
hello you mr. Campbell English teacher
probably a nice guy but a bit of a worm
and a sneak you guys has trickled who's
gonna fight Campbell yeah he's gonna
whip on bad two teachers they're in a
school fight to end all school fights
your brother teachers might fight the
whole schools into it with a tailgate
actions have consequences
this school is crazy [ __ ] is violet I
look like a million subtle lunatic
teachers ah thank you the guidance
counselor you're not doing meth again
right
mmm yeah yeah just a little bit don't do
meth cuz it's a gateway it's the finish
line it's gone down he's a nice guy and
the people are like hey I'm gonna stomp
on that guy I'm done with this [ __ ] no
more mr. nice guy
no we're playing by the rules BAM boom
that is gotta get in a fistfight
and hold you got this
I don't think he's got this why don't
you just take a punch and then just go
down wait dad like possums do or
anything that's like a like a [ __ ]
animal I'm gonna fight you I'm sorry
what parking lot after school its own he
just don't fight I want every